one of the craziest things about Isis is
how many people it recruits around the
world by one count over 20,000 people
have come to Iraq and Syria to fight
there most of them for Isis if that's
correct it would be a historical record
for the number of people who have
volunteered for this kind of conflict
why would anyone give up their life to
join a brutal vicious militant group one
that's fighting on all sides and in the
long run is facing a really long shot of
holding on to the territory it controls
it's a critically important question
because these foreign fighters are a
major source of Isis's strength many of
the people coming have not had a sense
of purpose had not had dignity or
respect or something to do a life
project and now that they have it one of
the things that makes Isis unique
relative to terrorist organizations that
came before it is the degree of
sophistication of their social media
operation Isis has invested a lot of
effort in developing a very slick social
media presentation including
sophisticated videos with narratives and
high production values they're clearly
focused on the glory of the battle and
of what the state has accomplished again
very inspirational for these young men
many of whom not all but most of whom
have not had a sense of purpose in life
and have not had any means to earn a
living to get married to do the kind of
things that they feel would bring them
into an adult life and now here's an
opportunity to prove themselves as young
men
in February 2015 the Islamic state was
able to shoot down and throw at 18 f-16
they captured the pilot they paraded him
before some of the bodies that his bomb
and resulted in some of the dead just
demonstrating that Jordanian aircraft
have brought death to civilians and of
course the constant imagery of the
charming when they burn him this is
about settling scores in in seeking
justice and so that is terribly
stimulating for these young men to see
that Isis's videos portray them as
saviors as heroes as people resisting
evil and violent regimes that are
pressed Muslims specifically Sunni
Muslims that way you motivate people who
might want to join Isis to go travel
around the world or and fight for what
they perceive as being justice that way
Isis a violent terrible brutal militant
group ends up being seen as the good
guys this isn't a small problem Isis has
recruited tens of thousands of people
this has made their military Empire
their stronger and because these foreign
fighters have so much conviction often
more radical and more dangerous for the
people that live there so these things
are serious problems and no one really
knows how to solve